liberté il y avait de l'activité devant
le Parlement ils étaient environ 200
rassemblées au plus fort de la journée
pour souligner la première année du
convoi de camionneur
l'année passée cette année pas de camion
pas de sauna ni Dieu gonflable les gens
sont venus à pied certains avec des
drapeaux musique et discours étaient au
rendez-vous on veut respecter la ville
de taureau les citoyens de Towa c'est ça
notre but c'est de repartir puis refaire
un peu notre image parce que l'image a
été affectée on a eu l'air barbare un
peu l'occasion de redorer leur image
selon l'organisateur Mathieu Vennes
le tout s'est déroulé sous haute
surveillance policière ce qui a donné
lieu à quelques moments de tension
qui rassure certains élus quand les gens
vont un peu prendre un peu plus de
confiance dans la police là parce qu'on
sait que ça a été très délicat les
dernières les derniers mois mais on a vu
avec le Rolling Stander avec le jour du
Canada ça allait de mieux en mieux l'an
dernier de nombreux commerçants avaient
dû fermer leurs portes en raison des
manifestations certains ont choisi de ne
courir aucun risque ce week-end et de
fermer à nouveau
donc c'est long on se retrouve
aujourd'hui ou certains commerçants ont
déjà décidé de fermer pour la fin de
semaine au cas où si certains
politiciens s'étaient affichés avec des
manifestants l'an dernier ils ont été
peu nombreux aujourd'hui
à part cette incursion du député
albertin un adversen au terme d'une
journée qui s'est déroulée relativement
dans le calme malgré quelques moments de
tension la police d'Ottawa a arrêté deux
personnes et a remis 20 avis
d'infractions provinciales les agents
municipaux eux ont remarqué 15 véhicules
et ont délivré 81 contreventions dans la
police que les agents municipaux
assurent qu'ils seront présents dans le
centre-ville tout le week-end il réitère
leur message que ce sera tolérance zéro
ici Rosalie Saint-Clair Radio-Canada
Ottawa